- Good evening everyone.
My name is MJ
and I'm part of the Migrant
Justice Initiative Project
at Yale University.
I am so excited that you joined us
for today's book conversation
between author Karla Cornejo Villavicencio
and Professor Albert Laguna.
Before we introduce each other,
we'd like to acknowledge
the stolen Quinnipiac land
on which Yale university stands
as well as the indigenous
peoples and nations
that have historically cared
for and maintained the land
which we now call Connecticut,
including the Mohegan,
Mashantucket Pequot, Eastern
Pequot, Schaghticoke,
Golden Hill Paugussett, Niantic,
and other Algonquian speaking peoples.
A little bit about the
Migrant Justice Initiative,
we are a multidisciplinary project
at the Yale Center for the Study of Race,
Indigeneity, and Transnational Migration
that aims to establish relationships
between scholars and migrant-led
social justice campaigns.
Our goal is to engage in
discussions of agency, mobility,
displacement, politics, and culture
from the perspective of migrants
in order to better
understand their realities
and the structures that shape them.
Our team currently includes:
Alicia, Katy Maldonado, Ramon,
Maggie Katz and MJ, myself.
And now I'd like to
introduce our moderator
and our speaker for today,
I'd like to begin with
Professor Albert Sergio Laguna,
he is an Associate Professor
of Ethnicity Race and Migration
and American Studies at Yale University.
His research and teaching
interests include,
transnational Latinx
literatures and cultures,
comparative ethnic studies,
performance studies,
and popular culture studies.
His work has appeared and is
forthcoming in Latino Studies,
The Journal of Latin
American Cultural Studies,
Latin American Research Review,
Contemporary Literature,
Cultural Critique, Diario
de Cuba, The Miami Herald,
The Washington Post, and on cnn.com.
Laguna's first book,
"Diversión: Play and Popular
Culture in Cuban America"
won numerous awards including
the 2018 Peter C. Rollins Book Prize
from the Northeast Popular
American Culture Association.
An article from his current book project,
"Edgardo Vega Yunqué
and the Comedy of Race,"
was awarded the L.S. Dembo Prize
from Contemporary Literature
for best article published
in that journal in 2018.
And then we have author
Karla Cornejo Villavicencio,
who is an immigrant
from Brooklyn in Queens,
Harvard graduate, Yale PhD student
and a writer who has contributed
to the New York Times,
The New Republic, Vogue, Elle, Glamor,
This American Life and more.
She is the author of The
National Book Award finalist,
"The Undocumented
Americans," a book of essays
and the upcoming young
adult novel, "Dream Girl."
She lives in New Haven with her partner
and her very cute dog.
And now I'd like to pass
it over to Professor Laguna
who will be moderating the panel.
- Hello, everyone.
I'd ask you how you're all doing
and you can maybe tell me
in the chat if you'd like.
Karla, more importantly,
how are you doing?
- I am okay, hello.
- Good to see you. Good to see you.
We had a little Frankie
Cameo there before the talk.
So I'm excited to have the whole kind of
crew there along with you.
So, you know, Karla, a
lot of people on this call
I'm sure have read this
book, but others have not.
So I thought we could start
with just a really basic you bringing us
into the world of the
undocumented Americans.
Why did you write this
book and what is it about?
What are you trying to do with it?
- I wrote this book as a response to
having grown up with
representations of immigrants
that I didn't feel were
true to my community
or my family growing up and I wrote it.
I began researching and writing it
the morning after Trump
won the presidency in 2016.
So it's very much like a snapshot in time
and I wanted to do something
different with the genre.
You know, I'd always, you know,
ever since you were like in high school,
one of the basic things you
learn in like English classes
that like, after like the A bomb
or after something like a world war,
there is like a change
in schools of literature.
And I felt that I didn't
want to wait around
to see what would happen,
you know, what would result
of the Trump presidency.
Like I was a child when 9/11 happened
and I remember people were wondering like
what would the 9/11
novel look like, right?
And I don't think they've been great,
but I do remember having a sense that
obviously things would
be bad for immigrants
during the Trump administration,
but also having a sense of what those,
what those like literary
works would look like
and wanting to provide an alternative.
- Hmm.
So, I mean, you're
providing an alternative to,
I guess what you imagined
the kind of fallout
has been of a Trump presidency,
the narratives around undocumented folks
but you're also providing an
important kind of intervention
in representations of the
undocumented immigrants
more broadly, I think,
in mainstream discourse.
You have this great
line, which reminds me,
I don't need much of a
reminder how funny you are
in this book, right?
There's moments of really great
lines, cutting comic lines,
but you say,
"You didn't want this
book to be a rueful tale
"about a sickly Victorian
orphan with tuberculosis
"that didn't have a
social security number."
So I'd love to hear a
little bit more about,
maybe like the biz side of this, right?
How the publishing industry in particular
sells the narrative of Latinx folks,
undocumented immigrants, more broadly,
first, second generation.
How you see the book in
conversation with those demands
and also if you could just
say a little bit about
now that the book has received
a lot of positive attention,
you know, what that experience
has been within the industry
as you continue to kind
of gain that visibility.
- I mean, can I just say, I
don't know who's on the call
because of the way this is set up.
(Karla laughs)
I'm feeling triggered right now
because I don't know how
many of the people here know,
Albert was one of my dissertation advisors
and before then one of my professors.
And he's known me since
I was like 21 or 22.
And even though on Instagram
I say I'm 26, I'm 31.
So your tone, your teaching
tone to me is very,
it just brings me back to when
I was like 23 and crying off,
(Karla laughing)
which I think in a lot of author
talks that doesn't happen.
So I'm going to (laughing),
I'm gonna try to answer your
questions without crying.
- Clarify first that, so
I don't get hate mail,
that it wasn't because I was
mean to you that you're crying
but because we were having
difficult conversations
or maybe I was mean to
you, you can clarify it.
- No, no, because he's a mentor.
And so it was like a
mix of academic queries
and sharing texts and this
would be inspirational to you
and you might wanna look at this resource,
let's do outlines.
I always benefit from outlines.
And also just like, my
20s were a time where
we're a decade long few state
and Albert was there for it.
So if there are any
national enquirers here,
Albert is willing to tell it all.
What was your question?
- What was the question?
Yes, I'm interested in the biz, right?
'Cause we've talked about
the publishing industry
kind of the narratives
they like to publish about
Latinx communities, undocumented
and not undocumented.
And just keen to hear a little bit about
how this book is pushing back
in conversation with those demands.
And also, you know, because
this book has received
The National Book Award, right?
I mean, it's getting a lot of attention
and it's taking you
probably into conversations
that you haven't had
before in the industry.
I'd like to hear just, you
know, your experience with that.
- Okay.
Well, it's, I mean, it's very interesting.
I received pushback at every single
step of trying to write this book
and publishing it and promoting it.
You know, not from, there's
some stuff that I can't say
because I'd like to
continue to make a living
throughout my life in publishing.
But the original draft of my book was
at another imprint that has now closed
and they rejected the book
because they called it
broken and unpublishable.
And it's this book.
And I asked why, and I
wasn't given a reason.
I was told that I was
going to be given a letter
explaining everything.
And I wasn't, I was just
given the line edits.
And the line edits were
typical edits that were like,
you might wanna move this clause here.
I won't reveal what happened later
but my editor protected my book
and it ended up in the hands
of Christopher Jackson,
who was an extraordinary
editor at One World
who edits Ta-Nehisi
Coates, Ibram X. Kendi,
and he added with us.
He really understood my
voice but it took him a lot,
a lot of time to understand me,
you know, and to understand,
to understand that there
could be someone like me,
a dreamer like me, who was,
who had different kinds
of loyalties, you know?
And so while he supported my vision,
he was a little bit confused by it
and probably had to do with me
having a difficulty
articulating my vision.
You know, for instance,
the magical realism that's in the book,
he thought that that
was going to make people
not believe in the reporting of the book.
And some of the reporting
is reporting that I break.
So like the stories of
the 9/11 cleanup workers
has been pretty under reported.
And he's like, "People
are not gonna believe that
"if you're just like,
you're making things up."
And like I was telling
you earlier, Albert,
I thought Elián González
was rescued by the dolphins.
And I listened to a podcast recently
where they were talking about
Elián and they were like,
"You know, these people who thought
"that he was rescued by the dolphins."
And I was talking to my
partner who is a white woman.
And I was like, I mean, I thought that
until I listened to the podcast.
Like I knew that that
wasn't literally real
but it is a kinda real, I mean,
in the sense that if a group of people,
a large enough group of people believe it,
and if their belief leads to a conclusion
that sustains them, then it is real.
I mean, it's a kinda real.
it's a kinda real that is, that has actual
material consequences in
people's lives, right?
And so the way I think
about magical realism
is super specific.
And so I explained it and what
we ended up doing in the book
is every instance of magical realism
ended up being a dream, you know?
But you know, every copy
editors, I, you know,
I received a lot of support
in my imprint from my editor,
but, you know, copy editors, proofreaders
would circle paragraphs
in my book and say,
"Are you sure you wanna say this?
"This is vulgar."
Or, "Are you sure you wanna say this?
"This is like, this is, you
know, this is really violent."
Or, "I don't think you,
"I don't think you wanna publish
something that says this."
Where I was like revealing
that I was cruel to my brother
or I was revealing
something dark but funny,
like a fantasy that I had
about drowning a toddler
which was not real, but it was,
it still revealed
something about my psyche.
And so I just had to, there's a,
I don't know if college students do this
but when you're in
editing, you just do stat
if you want to reject an edit.
And I was just, I take
edits, but when they're about
tone that people think
that I shouldn't be using
because as an immigrant I am
not entitled to that tone,
I just wrote stat, stat, stat a lot.
And then when it came up
to promoting the book,
you know, the thing they wanted
to lead with was that I was
a Harvard grad, one of the
first Harvard grads to go from,
you know, and I was like,
that doesn't position my
book as a literary book,
that positions that as a
dreamer memoir, which is not.
I don't talk about Harvard.
I don't talk about Yale.
I don't talk about any of that.
Like it's, I understood
why they had to do it
but then I had to work behind the scenes
to sabotage the marketing plans
and to reach out to individual
people, individual editors,
individual publications and
say, this is a literary book.
- I have a ton of questions
about the literary aspect
of this book that I wanna talk about,
but I do wanna put some more,
some more of the focus on
the kind of nuts and bolts.
And here I have a question about
this translation, you know,
'cause I was reading this
book the second time around
as a literary work, trying to understand
the different devices at work.
And just one word that
kept coming up in my head
was translation, right?
And your comments right now
make me think of translation again, right?
How it works as a concept in the book.
You talk about your beef with translation
in the context of journalists,
and often how they have to,
they fail to convey the complexity
of the language of their
Spanish speaking interlocutors.
You talk about translation
in the context of,
someone like Santiago at the worker center
who refuses to translate a pastor's sunny
liberal takes on America.
Then there's your own
approach to translating
the words of the folks
you engage with, right?
And translating your vision
for a broader readership.
And then I also want you to talk about
the question of translation,
translating this book into
Spanish and how that's going,
if it's going and you know,
what your thoughts are about it.
So if you could riff a
little bit about translation
as a kind of concept in this book
and your relationship to it,
I think that'd be really interesting.
- Yeah. I mean, I think
that I first became
acquainted with translation
as a narrative that white audiences
like to hear immigrant children talk about
or children of immigrant talk about,
like vis-a-vis our
relationship to our parents.
Like we translate for our
parents that makes us special
and that makes us worthy
of a special kind of pity
but also a special kind of attention.
And I'd like to like pull all,
you know, children of immigrants
who've applied to schools
using translation as part of
their college entrance essay.
I did.
I mean, I didn't write
about being undocumented
but I wrote a short story,
which I wasn't asked to,
where I focused on translation
and also about lying,
also about lying through translation.
And then it, you know,
dawned on me now that I'm 31
and I'm working on my healing
that translation from the
time that you were very young,
from the time that you're five years old,
not just basic translation
but like writing your own absence notes,
translating for your report cards,
translating at your own
therapist appointments,
translating at your mother's
gynecological appointments
where you may hear things about your dad
that you rather not know.
That's all part of like
this parentification thing
that children of immigrants go through
which is not our parents' fault.
It is part of the system
that we've fallen into
that is this monster of migration.
And it is not blaming anyone
to acknowledge that migration
where the powers that are
supposed to protect us
and create laws to guarantee
that we have humane and dignified
lives have neglected us.
And so that we, the children,
often have to become parent
figures to our parents.
And so translation is very fraught,
and it's not the romantic sweet thing that
white admissions officers think it is.
And so, yeah, translation was
interesting to me in the book.
It was interesting to me as a
writer because whenever I read
pieces of journalism that have,
like literally transliterated
Spanish, English to,
Spanish to English, there's
no art in the translation.
And so they just like use
like one word for one word
and it's, they make us all sound like
we have a kindergarten
level language capability
with absolute no nuance and
absolute no sense of humor,
absolute no sense of interiority.
And I'm like, that's not
how we sound like, you know?
Because when you read
us in the Spanish paper,
when you read us in the El Diario, like,
we're shady, we're like sassy,
we have conspiracy theories.
Like, why don't we sound like
that in the English paper?
And so my approach to
translating in this book was,
well, as a child of immigrants,
my thing is translating, right?
So I translated for my subjects
the way that I did for my parents.
So in real time, in real time,
and when it was time for me to,
and I didn't use recorders
because this was like 2016
and people, I did not wanna scare people.
As like Edith Grossman
who translates for like
García Márquez and stuff,
who translated for
García Márquez and stuff.
You have like certain number of words
that you could use to translate,
why choose the simplest word
to make you sound like
what you think we are,
which is like the simplest
possible common person
when you have these other
words that you could translate.
So, because I'm not an actual translator
or an actual journalist, I chose a word
that conveyed what I thought
the person meant, felt like,
if they were angry, sort of
like the spirit of the person,
I got to know my subjects really well.
So when you hear, when you
see their text in my book,
it sounds like you're talking to someone
that you know in your language,
and I didn't make any text up,
I didn't make any dialogue up.
It's their words.
I just translated the way
that a poet would translate,
you know, literary language,
which is, you do some rewriting
but you don't add, you just
choose the most beautiful
or the most evocative choices,
which I thought was a way of
giving back some dignity to our community
which has been infantilized.
And another thing, yes, my translation.
So my book, it was written in English.
My maternal language is Spanish,
but the language I write
in and think in is English.
I mean, I don't know if I can
talk about this but whatever.
So like my book was going to
be translated into Spanish.
And they hired a Latin American,
a white Latin American translator
for the Spanish translation.
So I spoke to this person and I said,
"My book has my philosophy
on translating."
And she said, "I don't agree."
And I said, "Okay, you do you boo."
But like, this is a very
clear voice in my book.
Like, it's very voicey.
And also my readers are
going to be like immigrants
and people connected to immigrants.
Like, I'm from New York, like I, you know.
And so I got the translation
back and it's in this like,
Sor Juana Inés de la Cruz,
aristocratic Spanish.
Like, okay, so I'm at the Yale
American Studies PhD program.
I applied to two American
Studies PhD programs in English,
Harvard and Yale, everything
else I applied for
was Spanish PhD programs
or Latin American PhD programs in Spanish.
Like, I get it.
I got it.
The editors thought it was a class thing.
He told me, like, we
can try to get this to
sound more like street Spanish.
And I was like, "Excuse me, sir,
"do you know that Latinx Spanish
is a different vernacular
"than the Latin American or
aristocratic Spanish, sir?"
And then it just wasn't worth
my time because like I said,
I'm on a healing journey and I
just don't waste that energy.
Like Shakira says in that song,
"You don't throw pearls
to the pigs," you know?
I was not going to change his mind.
My editor tried to speak
on my behalf and say,
"Karla's right," like,
"You have to get a different translator."
Do you know what he said to me?
The typical response of racist white men
who say that there are
no qualified candidates.
He said that he couldn't
find a Latinx translator,
a qualified Latinx translator.
And I said, "CUNY has a
program for translation."
And then he was difficult
about it and he said no.
So I pulled the translation
and I just knew the book
was going to continue
to be more successful and
I was gonna win more awards
and I was going to have
my choice of translator
at some point because like,
what's the point of publishing
a book that's going to sound
like an Argentine on ecstasy
masturbating to himself?
This book is written by
and for Latino immigrants
and immigrant adjacents.
If it's not gonna sound like
that, then it doesn't exist.
- Okay, I think we have the
title of your next book there
in our next hard hitting articles.
The reception of this
book, and, you know, this,
it's actually really
interesting to hear that, right?
'Cause it gives you a sense of,
you know, when you think of,
how a book like yours
makes it through the world
of the US publishing industry,
you know, you ever think about
the kind of translation to
the Spanish aspect of it.
I think that's very telling
and perhaps not too surprising.
You know, I'd really appreciate
that riff on translation.
And it really just hits home, like how,
how well you do the job
of translation, because,
you know, the measure
for me for that is that
I remember the people
distinctly that you talk about
and you're speaking with
in your book, right?
It's not just like a
mass of people, right,
with different, I remember
names and like situations
and that's because
you're giving us a person
through their words, right?
And that's because of your
skill as a translator, right?
So, you know, I wanna
illuminate that a bit more,
your relationships with these people
'cause it's such a big part of the book.
It's what makes the book the book, right?
So I'd love for you to
say a bit more about
how you made those connections,
develop that intimacy,
but I really, I'm more interested
secretly, not so secretly,
in the failures of connection
that you talk about.
You talk about it in a couple
of different ways, right?
I think it's really important
you don't shy away from the fact that
you failed multiple times, right,
to connect with people, right?
And I think those failures are,
dare I say, generative, right?
So I'd love to hear more about that,
the relationships you cultivated
and you couldn't cultivate, right?
I think that's--
(Karla chuckles)
- Which relationships
are you speaking about?
- Well, I always think about the,
when you're in, is it
Cleveland and, or, no Flint,
when the students, you're
like, "Let's go to New York."
And they just kinda like looked at you,
and you're, the trouble you had
connecting with some of
the teenagers, pre-teens--
- That was, yeah.
- Put in context.
I mean, you know, you bring
a lot of commonalities
and kind of common ground with
these people to connect with
but there're also big differences, right?
You're light trajectory and the
people you're speaking with.
So yeah, I'd love to hear
about those relationships
because they are core, right, to the book.
- So that was very,
the Flint chapter was very
painful for me to write
because it's something that I,
that is unresolved within me.
And I know I can't,
I have no idea who's on this
call other than Alicia face
and Steve's S, big S on the screen.
I know a lot of you, you know,
Latinx youth who are here at Yale
might be able to relate to this but
when you've heard from the,
you know, from your earliest memories
that the way of getting
out is through education.
And it just happens
through strokes of luck
and genetic accidents that
you have no control over
and work ethic.
But you also know that your like
uncle has incredible work ethic
and your undocumented aunt
has like great work ethic.
And your cousin that works
at Walmart has great ethic
and then you're like,
well, it's not just the work ethic, right?
And you understand that it's just like
kind of Russian roulette.
And you're like, okay, so I did this,
I did this the right way.
And then as you grow
older you realize that
it changes a lot of things
and it doesn't change a lot of things.
You know, some like right-wing websites,
like, you know, try to
take me on and be like,
the way to fame and fortune
is to be an illegal alien.
And it's like, well, I'm a queer icon now
but I definitely don't have no fortune.
I know that college is not
the answer for everybody,
but I also have a knee-jerk reaction
if a young person comes up
to me and ask for advice
to say, go to four-year
school, go to four-year school.
I can't not.
And if a young person says
that they wanna do something in art,
I need to know what their art looks like.
And I need to personally
evaluate if I think that they are
going to be able to make money off of it.
And if I don't think they are,
I will break their fucking heart and say,
"I think you can do this as a hobby
"but I think you should go
into engineering," you know?
And a lot of people, including my partner,
think I'm a monster.
She teaches in education studies.
And so she, you know, she
has a lot of kids of color
who wanna be teachers.
And sometimes I get them
on the sly and I'm like,
"Hey, have you thought about law school?"
You know?
(Karla laughs)
And it's just because
I know a lot of these kids
have to support their parents
until they die.
And I worry about how they're
going to be able to do that
on a public school teacher salary,
on an elementary school
public teacher salary.
And it's not my business
but I also just worry.
And I haven't solved it for myself
because I took an arts career,
I'm doing okay in terms of
recognition, laurels but I'm
not making money off of it.
But I've also been lucky
enough to support my parents
throughout the pandemic.
And that's, I sort of
feel like, like that is,
you know, like the J-Lo movie, "Enough"
where she was just like,
does all of the like,
like all of the trainings to
get ready to beat her abuser.
I was like, I did all of this
to be able to support my parents
'cause I knew a pandemic was coming
and they needed to live off of me
because otherwise they
would literally die.
And I want all of these
children of immigrants
who come to me asking
for advice or who don't,
I want them to be able to have that.
At the same time, I don't
want them to be unhappy
and choose careers that kill their souls.
So that's the Flint chapter where I try to
reach out to young teens and say like,
"Look at me, don't you
have big Broadway dreams?"
And they're like, "No,
I mean, I wanna just,
"that place has great tips
"and they probably make
more money than I do."
But then I, like, I'm
like really heavy handed
and I'm like, "Have you
thought about health insurance?
"Have you thought about savings?"
And I just can't help but be that person
because of my traumas.
And I felt that the most
honest way to handle that
instead of somehow pretending
that I've solved that for myself
is just being totally,
like we say, in Spanish,
(speaks in Spanish), just being like,
look, I'm a product of
programs, like prep for prep.
And I'm a product of
knowing that I was hungry,
went hungry as a child.
And that I had this one
thing that I was good at
that it turns out I could make money from.
And now I want,
it's sort of like I remember
Kendrick Lamar saying
in an interview that he,
I mean, what he does now
is that he hires a lot of
talented kids from Compton
to work for him.
And I don't know how that's
going, but he says that like
the first time that he
was at a nice hotel,
he wished that he could just like,
like fly in all the kids from Compton
and just put them in that one hotel.
And I think its a lot of survivor's guilt
and I think it's a lot of hoping that
the magic spell that worked
for you even a little
worked for everybody else.
And I think a lot of
people struggle with it
and I think that no
one wants an answer but
acknowledging the struggle is
what a lot of people needed.
- I think, I mean, it's
important for you to say that
and say it out loud.
My next question was
going to be about that
tension between the,
you know, the password for the kids in,
outside of Cleveland, right?
Study hard and your anxiety is
about giving that kind of the
the advice about education but,
I think it's important to hear
because so much of the
story is follow your dreams,
do what you love.
But for a lot of people they can't,
or it's not that easy
to make that decision.
So to show that you're
wrestling with it, I think is,
in the book is really, is
really important and productive.
You know, I wanna move
now, looking at the clock,
to the question of this book
as capital L literature, right?
And art, right?
Because I think that's such an
important part of this book,
the contribution that it's making
is that it will be the subject of many
English PhD dissertations.
- There's not enough there.
(Karla laughing)
- Oh yeah, oh yeah, don't worry.
I'm already starting to assign it.
The pipeline, you know, we're
working on that pipeline.
Someone has to be the Karla
Cornejo Villavicencio chair of,
of American studies somewhere.
- Oh no, please don't, I'll
send a cease and desist.
(Professor Laguna laughing)
- Well, I think I just wanna take a line
from your intro, right?
And I wanna ask you to
unpack it a bit, right?
Where you say, "When you are
an undocumented immigrant
"with an undocumented family,
"writing about undocumented immigrants,
"and I can only speak
for myself and my ghosts,
"it feels unethical to put it
on the drag of a journalist.
"It is also painful to focus on the art
"but impossible to process the
world is anything but art."
So I just want you to just unpack,
what does it mean to process this world
that you're writing about as art?
Why is it important?
And if you can clarify even,
what's the creative and
creative non-fiction, right,
that you're kind of
harnessing in this narrative?
- Well, I mean, for me it
was important to, you know,
I studied under Kate Dudley at Yale.
And so I had an understanding
of like ethnographic writing
and even like ethnographic
creative writing
and ethnographic fiction.
So I referred to my subjects
of my subjects, but I also
while I was writing my book,
I made a conscious decision
to write about them as characters
because I wanted them to be,
like really rich people who,
you know, had weight.
And so it's sort of like
when you build a character from scratch
and now that I'm writing a novel,
it feels harder to do with a novel.
But I wrote them as characters.
I wanted them to hold up to scrutiny.
And in order to do that, I
had to do a lot of interviews
where I just didn't ask them,
how many times did you cross the desert?
Do you send remissions to your family?
Like, what does it mean to be American?
That's not how you write
a character, right?
That's how you sort of
fill out a census form.
So what I did was I just
talked to them about
just really boring things and just,
like not a lot happens in my book.
There's not really much plot.
Like one of the stories
that people seem to respond to a lot
and one of the loveliest
conversations I had was with,
I forget the name I give him in the book
'cause I changed everyone's names but
a man in the Flint chapter who
worked at a chocolate factory
and who had two pit bulls
and that's all I say about him, really.
He worked at a chocolate
factory and then he got fired
and he gave his filtered
water to his two pit bulls.
And usually in a story
where you have like,
you know, a piece of art about immigrants,
you want like a story, you
want there to be trauma,
you want there to be action,
you want there to be,
but then nothing happens here.
It's just that.
But the way that I was
able to write about him
and sort of like the
slow sort of pace that
people really responded to was that I,
you know, I sort of built
him up like a paper doll.
I cared about him
and I think you can tell
that when you read the book
and I thought what made
him so special was that
people think about us as
people who will do jobs
Americans won't do.
We're just like really hard
workers or like whatever.
But here's a man who
took like great delight
and great dignity in having this really
this job that he loved
with these fantastic smells
and where at the end
they thought that they
could infantilize him
by giving him a certificate that was like,
you did great, bud, when
they fired him for no reason.
And the fact that
when people think of
undocumented immigrants,
they're not gonna think that
someone loved his rescue
pit bull so much that
they would give them
their own filtered water
during a water crisis.
No one's gonna think that.
You know, that is such a
beautiful humanizing detail.
And I thought that says so much,
that says so much.
Yeah, so it was, you know,
it was things like that
that I think really build a character.
So for me it wasn't about
representing subjects
because representing subjects for me,
I think could be just like,
you already have in your mind
what you wanna say about
them, like hardworking,
you know, family values, pays
his taxes, you know, whatever.
But I wanted see what was,
you know, what made that
person special and everything,
you know, there's good special,
bad special, weird special
but every person has a little something.
And so I just treated people as characters
and I think that's what made it creative.
- Yeah, I think, you know,
when you're talking about the smells
since you've began
talking about this person,
I was instantly transported to
kind of sensory experience
of reading a text.
I can almost smell the floor
of that candy factory, right?
So again, effective.
And I'm kind of, you
know, I want candy now.
So if I can ask you to go a
little bit more on this kind of,
this question of creativity, right?
I wanna ask you about the moment
that people always ask you about, right?
The way you imagined
the death of Ubaldo Cruz Martínez, right?
'Cause I'm particularly
attracted to what you say on,
after you relate his story
after drowning in a basement
with Hurricane Sandy, you say,
"What if this is how
"in the face of so much
sacrilege and slander,
"we reclaim our dead?"
So the question of imagination and art,
it's how I'm kind of
connecting the dots here.
So can you say a little
bit about that moment
because it is such a, I think
key moment for unpacking
the way kind of creativity
is working in this text
and how you think the work of creativity,
why you think it's important?
- You know, I just, he was,
his is the only occasion in the book
where I use someone's real name.
I use pseudonyms for
everyone except for him.
All of the daily laborers that I knew
and I became very close to,
the day laborers in Staten Island,
most of them knew him or knew of him.
And when I talked to them
about him, there was a sense of
slight, I guess there was a lot of sadness
with slight embarrassment
because of the way he died.
And what was originally in
the book and I cut out was
for no reason other than
space or just editing was that
if I died right now, if I was
just in like a freak accident,
slipped and hit my head,
because of who I am,
which is just like a loud spoken person
who is unapologetic
about being undocumented,
an autopsy, or, you
know, the results of that
would probably be made political.
And what it would reveal is,
like up for literary
interpretation, you know?
I'm on a lot of medications
in order to keep me alive.
And given the day, given
how hard things are,
given how unstable or kind or
unboundaried my parents are,
given the political news of the day,
like beside from the medications I'm on
which lay men don't have understanding of,
and some of those medications
are scary-sounding
like anti-psychotics, right?
They don't know what they're treating.
They're used off-label
to treat my borderline
personality disorder.
But there's also, you know,
I might have a
benzodiazepine in my system.
I might have taken a drink,
I might have had a lot of kombucha
which might represent for
some level of alcohol.
You know, I might have
taken a beta blocker
because that stops my panic attacks
because it slows down my heart rate.
You know, it might've been a day
where I had a really
big deadline that night
and I might've taken an Adderall.
And if someone did a toxicology report,
they would have said like,
"Look at your little dreamer," you know?
"Look at all of the substances she's on."
And nobody deserves to
have a toxicology report
or any phase in their
life define who they are
or what their journey in
this country has been like.
Because like Albert, you know
me, like I'm doing okay now
but there have been times
in my 20s and during Yale
where I was not doing okay
and I did not handle my
mental health issues well.
And my mental health issues
were intimately tied to my immigration
and the fact that I did not know
they were tied to my immigration.
And I was sort of walking around blindly
and I did not receive culturally sensitive
mental health treatment for them.
And I was, you know, I fell
asleep in coffee shops.
I passed out in places.
I like vomited blood
outside of lecture halls.
What if like that had been the moment
where I had become public
and that had been the name
people remembered me by?
So once you have that in your head,
you understand that
immigration affects us all
as we are all immigrants,
in the sense that we are all immigrants.
And I didn't think it was
fair that that was his death
because a lot of people
drink during storms.
He was drinking during the hurricane.
A lot of people drink during storms
and it just happened that he died.
And so I thought that as someone who has
total power over what I put on the page,
I could either report it the
way that newspapers reported it
which was this alcoholic
daily laborer drowned
'cause he was, you know, cause of vice
or because of the understanding
that I had about the life
that migration takes on a
body and on a mind and a soul,
I could envision a
different ending for him.
And it was a reclamation.
And I felt that that reclamation
was for him personally
because my heart dictated I
make it but it was also for me,
it was also a reclamation for
the different people that
have been in my life.
And the kind of political
pinata I could have been
at different points in my life
or could still be, you know?
In the end it was an artistic call
for compassion and empathy
and also a reminder to my
less sympathetic readers
that so long as they're
holding my pages, I am god
and I control what happens in this book.
That's really great that, you know,
now I'm gonna read that
scene with a new set of eyes.
I really appreciate that explanation.
And also just, you know,
that moment in the book,
just, it's pushing back against
so much of even the
literature in Latinx studies
or the mainstream discourse which is,
try to count the undocumented,
it's about policies,
it's about labor, right?
So like making a space for
art and the imagination,
I think is so important to
what I love about this book so much.
You know, I have some, let's
see what time it is, 5:50.
This is kind of a, it's just
a, it's kind of a me question.
I just really wanna know.
Writing this book was clearly not easy.
So I'm really curious just because
I wanna get in your
head a little bit here,
but what were you listening to and reading
while you were working through
this, I'm very curious.
- At the beginning, I read
a lot of James Baldwin
to muster up the courage
to write this because I,
I mean, I love his writing obviously,
but I also knew that he had
a reluctance to write about
some of the things he did
because it affected him immensely
and he felt that it was an
obligation to give back,
as he said, to the people who made him,
to the people who he owed.
And so I read a lot of him.
And then I mostly stopped reading.
I read some Jenny Diski because
I liked her voice but I,
and I read a lot of Eileen
Myles who became a friend.
And I love Eileen's,
I love Eileen's voice.
And there's sort of nobody who can,
nobody's books who I read and then go,
I really wanna right now,
you know, other than Eileen.
But mostly I listened to a lot of music.
And I think you can sort of tell
with the cadence of my sentences
that I was going for something that was
kind of disjointed and chaotic
but also really tightly controlled,
something that was like written
and then played chaotically.
And so I listened to a lot
of like The White Stripes
and I listened to a lot of Fiona Apple
and I listened to a lot of
Nirvana and the Arctic Monkeys.
And it's so funny, the
Arctic Monkeys have,
their songwriter, Alex Turner,
he writes some really weird
lyrics that if I try to write
would totally get edited out.
But if I can say is that
like everything that I tried to edit out,
everything that anyone tried
to edit out of this book,
any sentence, and that I fought for
have now become my reader's
favorite sentences or passages.
- Hmm, Hmm.
That's, now I have a soundtrack
for when I read the book.
I appreciate that, I'm taking notes here.
Maybe two or three more questions
before we open up to the Q&A.
I'm gonna ask you, ha
ha, kind of fiendishly
to go back to your TF days, right?
I'm curious about how
would you teach this book
or if you don't wanna answer
that question, you know,
maybe the question is,
you know, what do you want
readers in college maybe
to get out of this book?
But if you wanna put on the TF hat,
you know, you're more
than welcome to do that.
- Like I have no recollection
of my time as a TF.
And sometimes like students,
I mean, they've graduated
but like they would have been like, "Hey."
And I'd be like, "Hey," I
did not remember any of them.
You know what's crazy?
I have gotten a lot of
messages from young people,
college students who
are saying that they are
comfortable experimenting
with the essay form
and with first person writing
and like that's based on
heavy research and interviews
and that their professors
are actually encouraging them
to do creative projects and
personal essays based on
a lot of interviews and
"Reportage" and research.
And all of these kids who
write me are kids of color.
And I think that that's fantastic.
I have like throughout
high school until now
I have forced that to be the
case for me in all my classes.
But the fact that I think,
you know, I have a friend
who's an immigration journalist
and she just got her first book deal.
And she said that her editor
told her, like cited my book
and said that she was allowed
to write in the first person
which before, as a journalist,
you were not allowed to do.
And so I think that, even
though my book is still not like
huge, you know, it's been
really a grassroots support
of a lot of Latinx people and a lot of
immigrants and children of immigrants
and people of color
who supported the book,
I think that a lot of people
who are assigning the book
or in the publishing industry have,
I don't know why it took them so long,
but have noticed that this
is something you can do
and are validating the
genre of the personal essay
that's based on reporting
and interviews and,
you know, pop culture references
and all of this genre that I worked with.
And they, you know, it's kind
of like Dave Eggers released
"A Heartbreaking Work
of Staggering Genius"
and they were like
a lot of Dave Eggers is
after that, you know?
I was one of them.
- So in the future when I teach your book,
I'll send you my students' comments
and, you know, reader's responses
so you can be in the kind
of room as a TF, right?
But, you know, you've mentioned
a little bit about your,
the response that the book has received,
your direct messages
about students feeling
an ability to experiment
with form and genre.
Can you say a little bit more
about that grassroots support
and is there responses
from folks you're getting?
- Yeah, I mean, at
first I was the only one
who bet on this book, like
nobody believed in this book.
My editor loved my voice, but
I don't think he understood
that this book was as special as it was.
It was entirely Latinx
readers on social media
who discovered this book and
not just like young people
in their college chucking
colleges but it was like
from college age to like
children, like older,
mature, older children
of like the original
(speaks in Spanish) who were like,
I've been waiting my entire
life to see a book like this.
Who were really emotional and would like
send me videos of them unboxing my book.
And then like the younger
kids would be like
sending videos of them
twerking to my book.
And it was, I mean, it was really amazing.
I got messages from black
immigrants, African immigrants,
who just felt like they
didn't really belong in
the Latinx activist movement
because of its politics
that I haven't really aligned myself with.
And they felt a little bit excluded
from the Black Lives Matter movement.
And they really found a home in my book.
And I've gotten a lot
of messages from like
children of Asian immigrants
who really loved the book.
I've gotten messages from disabled readers
who have felt comfortable
with the fact that
so much of what makes someone
documented, not documented,
a citizen, not citizen, smart,
not smart, good at SATs,
all of this is luck and they understand
the role that luck can
play in a person's life
and the way that like can look,
can determine whether or not
you're discriminated against
or not for the rest of your life.
And I, you know, I've had a lot of,
you know, really successful
Latinx children of immigrants
understand my brain and share
it and share that with me.
And also, you know, I'm
very open on Instagram
about my mental illness
and how hard work it is
to stay high functioning
and stable and to,
how sometimes we judge whether
or not we're doing okay
with our mental health
by how productive we are.
But I also try to make sure that I find
some space for joy every day.
And I've had a huge response
of Latinx kids being like,
I am not doing well and I,
you know, want to work on my mental health
and that's meant the most to me.
- Thank you for that.
My last question before
we get to the Q&A is just,
you know, what's the next thing?
You know, you teased it a
little bit, sounds like a novel.
I'd love to hear a little
bit more about that.
And maybe what, you know, to
focus on the art again, right?
That shift from the undocumented Americans
to the novel as a form.
I'd love to hear about that as well.
- Yeah, the novel, it's
a young adult novel
and it's sort of loosely
based on my teenage years
in New York city, writing
about music as a teenager
and like being in that underground,
the undocumented underground and the like,
you know, multiple
undergrounds in New York.
And it's like a very fast paced, gritty,
pre-gentrified New York book.
It's as if a beatnik
was a queer, undocumented
Jehovah's Witness girl in Brooklyn
who was rescued by a public
masturbator, by a drag queen
before her Jehovah's Witness
dad picked her up at midnight
at a jazz club in the village,
like that's the novel.
And then after that, I have
a book of essays on cults.
- Cults, spring, period.
All right.
(Professor Laguna laughs)
Yes, Q&A.
Let's go to the Q&A.
The first question is, one attending notes
your interest in shifting the
spotlight from the dreamer
and onto the everyday
undocumented immigrant.
Can you say more about how we
might continue these efforts
on a nationwide political level?
- I have no policy recommendations.
(Karla and Professor Laguna laughing)
I mean, I don't know.
If you're genuinely interested,
if you were like someone who
works on in policy spaces
or like in activism spaces,
you can contact Jose Antonio Vargas.
He does that sort of how to get from
hearts and minds to politics.
I don't do that.
Sorry.
- Well, what you do do is so important,
is that you're giving people,
you know, they're gonna be people,
you know, in 15, 10, 15
years probably even sooner,
like, you know, I had my Karla stage
where the undocumented Americans
is really important for me, right?
You're opening up a space
for people to imagine
these communities, right,
in different ways, right?
And I think that's perhaps
not, that's not a policy memo,
but it is extremely
important as, you know,
as people in the humanities
at least like to think.
I include myself among them.
Okay, so more questions.
Can you say more about the
cover image of the book?
This is from Laura Wexler.
- Hi, Laura Wexler.
Yes.
The updated cover image of the book is,
oh, I have it here so everyone can see it.
It's this flower.
And here are the USCIS documents,
USCIS which is being
bankrupted intentionally,
Stephen Miller brainchild.
And then there are bloodstains
which I requested to be all around there.
And so I didn't have any control
over why that flower was there.
The flower was always there.
And I was like, okay.
And I then came up with the
explanation that it was like,
like I've always written
about animals and wildlife
and inhospitable places
like the Sonoran Desert
or under like the deepest
fathoms of the sea
and compared undocumented people to that
because we survive in
inhospitable climates
that want us dead, right?
So I think that's what they
derived inspiration from.
And then I wanted the
papers thing with the blood
because as someone
who's gone through DACA,
got a temporary green card that expired,
I think a lot of people
who've experienced,
who've been undocumented and
have experienced legalization
or who have been citizens
and then had to petition
their parents for legalization
and then now in this era
has seen that fall through all of that,
there's a lot of guilt, there's
a lot of survivor's guilt,
there's a lot of guilt.
And you always feel like you
have blood on your hands.
And I wanted to acknowledge the fact that
one, immigrants are world makers.
We make worlds out of thin air.
And two, the idea of papers,
having papers is always in the background.
But even when you have
it, it never goes away.
The trauma doesn't go
away and the feeling that
you've left people behind doesn't go away.
- So another question, what
are the things you do for joy?
How do you find joy when
things feel harder than ever?
- You know, it's a funny thing.
This is, well, Albert, you don't know this
but when I was Albert's grad
student, I was like 23 or 24,
I used to go to his office,
clearly looking a mess.
And Albert would like, like slide over
a Ziploc bag of calming herbal tea to me
and be like, "I think you
should take this home."
Okay, so one of the
things that I do now is
I try to find like sensory things
that I can look forward to every day.
So one of the things is like
showering and putting on
like fragrant body lotions and body oils
because that's like a mindful thing
that if you disassociate,
which if you have trauma
you probably do in some way,
it connects you to your body
and it also, you know,
connects you to your senses.
I also drink a lot of like turmeric tea.
And it's kind of like a
Pavlovian thing where like
alcohol reminds me of like,
I'm about to make a call to my dad
and I need to calm down my nerves.
But whereas like turmeric
tea or turmeric latte,
which is just putting
turmeric thing in like water
and then putting some milk in it,
it reminds me that I'm
taking care of myself.
So the more that I do it,
the more it becomes a reminder to myself
that I'm taking care of myself.
I'm working on finding joy.
I like birds.
We should've talked more
with Albert about birds.
So I like feeding them.
And I have this book by,
what's Sibley's first name?
- David.
- David Sibley has a,
I read Sibley's books on birds
when I'm feeling like super
stressed and triggered
because birds are beautiful and resilient.
So find something that's not
immigration-related, not,
don't be like, okay, so I'm
gonna take care of myself,
I'm gonna read Audre Lorde.
No, like find like birds.
Before, when I used to be really crazy,
I used to watch videos of grizzly bears.
Just like, just take
humans out of the picture.
Just, just look at a leaf, you know?
I really recommend that.
- I second the birds.
And for those of you wondering
what tea I was pushing in
my office, it was Tilo,
which is in English, Linden flower.
(Karla laughs)
Yes, it's good calming tea.
I drink a lot of it,
that's why it was in my office.
So another question,
can you say a bit more
about your writing process,
where and how you write,
how you manage moments when
the writing is not flowing?
- Well, when I have like
a lot of time, I'm like,
I pretend that a lot of things matter
such as like inspiration
and I like, you know,
ultimately, all of it is bullshit
and when you have, when
you're on deadline,
all that matters is like that
you sit down and you write.
What helps is an outline.
What helps the most is an outline.
So I'm writing a piece for
The New Yorker right now
and my editor made me an outline.
And when I don't have
someone making me an outline,
my partner, Talia, makes me an outline.
And when I had the book,
what I did was I printed out
chapters of the book and I cut,
Albert, I don't know if you know this,
I cut out paragraphs, all the paragraphs,
and sometimes individual sentences
and then I would tape them on my floor
in the order in which they were
meant by the gods to appear
which is actually the way Nabokov's wife
organized his index cards.
'Cause he would write
his book in index cards
and then she reorganized them
in the way they were supposed to appear.
'Cause I am not a linear thinker
and so outlines help a lot.
Talia, my partner, is a fantastic teacher
and she makes all her
students do outlines.
So I would say like,
I believe in like burning
palo santo, candles, skincare,
moisturizing, doing my
makeup, hair, like matcha,
all of that until like I'm on a deadline.
And then I just like put
on a one-piece bathing suit
and just sit on my bed and just do it.
- Well, this is a related
question because it's what,
part of what makes your
writing so distinctive
is that your voice, right?
How did you, can you tell us
more, and this is a question,
can you tell us more about the
process you've gone through
to develop and refine your
distinctive writerly voice?
- Yeah.
I think one of the things you
first start doing is you start
first you discover things you don't like,
voices you don't like.
So Albert knows that I
spent most of my time
as a grad student being like,
I hate this, I hate this.
And then I would list
everything that I hated.
And I wish I had spent more time
finding out things that I liked.
So at first I think as a young writer,
you write against things and you,
and you shouldn't spend the
rest of your career doing that
because some people do, some people do,
just develop a voice that's
just like anti-things
but then they don't develop
a voice of their own.
I would say read a lot but
not only like novels or books,
but like good TV writing.
Like I was obsessed with "30 Rock."
I've watched it like
seven straight through.
And that's like, there's
like, I think there's like,
there's like, like a record
number of references per minute.
And like, my writing is
very reference heavy.
So like that really inspired me.
I watched a lot of "SNL" that inspired me,
a lot of rock and roll that inspired me.
Like anywhere that's good writing,
like good writing can also be like,
I remember when I was little,
this is not no longer the case
but when Vitaminwater
first came out, the copy,
the back copy of Vitaminwater
used to be pretty witty.
And I remember being like in
the fifth grade and being like,
"I wanna write for Vitaminwater one day."
You know, like wherever
you can find good writing,
like not just books, but
just let it inspire you.
And that's where your voice
is going to be like expansive.
So that's why I tell kids,
like if you are like Latinx
and you wanna be a writer, don't just read
like Anzaldúa, you know what I mean?
Just like read expanse,
watch movies, watch movies,
but don't just watch like
classics, watch like,
watch everything, watch
"Paris Is Burning," you know?
Like watch videos on how
to vogue and realize like
what different storytelling
looks like, you know?
Like watching big performances.
I like watching big performances,
like, yeah "Homecoming,"
Beyonce's "Homecoming,"
like Freddie Mercury, like
how is a good performance?
How is like storytelling done?
And I think that's how you
pick up like a lot of like
influences and then when
you sit down on the page,
you can be you but I'll
tell you the truth,
when I first started writing,
I used to sit down and I used,
in order to get me hyped up to write,
I used to be like,
okay, such and such essay by Lorrie Moore,
such and such essay by Joan Didion.
And I used to try to imitate their voices.
And I think that was a good exercise
because then you can see
what like ticks they have,
what tricks they have.
And so like, I can do pretty good parodies
of like Hemingway, Fitzgerald,
Joan Didion, García Márquez, all of them.
And like Gertrude Stein, who
is a huge influence of mine,
partly because I learned to parody her.
So maybe like try to parody
some of your favorite writers.
And then I dunno, I dunno,
you should not take life advice from me
but that's the stuff that
I did when I was younger.
- I wanna read the parodies of these,
of Fitzgerald, Hemingway, Stein.
I wanna read, that reminds me of,
Reinaldo Arenas does that for like
the canon of Cuban
writers in a book called,
"La Loma del Angel."
So I would love to read
Karla's version of this
for the canon of American literature.
- The Hemingway one is up on McSweeney's.
- Is it?
Have I seen it already?
I've probably seen it.
Okay, more on that later.
So the questions are, you
know, jumping around topics,
that's fine, that's why we have a Q&A.
So another question asks,
can you talk about how you
navigated these immigrant spaces
from your interviews to
your personal interactions,
as someone who is open and unapologetic
about mental health and queerness?
- And queerness?
- Yes.
- Okay, so this pixie is new
and I didn't look like this
when I went on my interviews,
but I was open, I was open.
So I'll be sincere.
So first of all for all
of the day laborers,
they had an organizer who
is named Pedro in the book
who is gay and openly gay.
And the way he organized
them was to be like,
if you were discriminated against,
here are other groups who
we're discriminated against.
In the daily laborer worker center,
there are groups for LGBTQ people,
there are groups for trans people.
So they knew that they,
that they had to be respectful, you know?
And they all love him.
It was a complete safe space for me.
And I had never, I had,
like with all the people that I spoke to,
and most of the people that I
spoke to for my book were men,
I had one experience and it
was with an American citizen
where I felt uncomfortable as a woman.
And it was over text.
Everyone was completely
appropriate with me.
And so I would, I think
that people really felt,
something that helped was
that I pitched them the book.
So the pitch that I gave, like
the publishers to sell them
was the pitch that I gave immigrants.
I wanted them to understand
why I was writing
because a lot of them had
experiences with people from like
"Univison" and "Telemundo"
coming taking their pictures
to getting interviews
and then like bouncing
and then never seeing them again.
And that's not what I wanted to do.
Like, I still have some
people that I love who are
in these communities that I
check in on them and make sure
that they're doing okay during
COVID, that they, you know,
I wanna make sure that I,
that they can count on me
should things become catastrophic.
I didn't tell them that at the time,
but I went into the
communities and I was like,
"Look, so my name's Karla, I'm on DACA.
"I am a dreamer.
"I don't identify as a dreamer.
"Here's why I don't identify as dreamer.
"My parents are undocumented.
"I have a complicated
relationship with my parents.
"Here's why."
I was like, "This is
the book I wanna write.
"Here's why books that I
have written about migrants
"that I've read I feel fall short.
"Here's why I think we
have not been represented
"in a way that I'd like
to see us represented.
"Here's why I think I
can do that differently.
"Do you trust me to try?"
I felt like it would
have been condescending
for me to just be like,
"Hey, can I interview
you about your life?"
Without telling them
what I was trying to do
with their stories.
And they responded really
well to that, you know?
They were like, "Yeah, people
think we're alcoholics.
"Yeah, people."
And I think like in one of my chapters
where it's like middle-aged
women who are like,
"Yeah, we're tired of our husbands.
'We married too young."
Like, "I'm having like
a feminist awakening now
"and I wanna go party."
Like, that would not have been possible
if I had not told them
that I was trying to
change stereotypes and
caricatures of immigrants.
They would've just been like,
"Yes, so we are, we are
activists," you know?
They would have told me the story
they thought I was trying to get.
And so one was that,
another thing is that,
like my Spanish is a very formal,
like church Spanish, mom and dad Spanish.
So I reminded them of
their kids and grandkids.
And during the writing of the book
I had like pink hair,
purple hair, green hair.
I had these tattoos and
some of them would be like,
"You have a lot of tattoos,
"what do your parents think about that?"
And I was like,
"What do you think my
parents think about that?"
And, you know, it just became like,
I was my self around them
and I just reminded them of
their kids and grandkids who assimilated
and who they were just shaking
their heads at, you know?
I looked like them.
I had their same status.
The Yale thing didn't
mean anything to them.
They were proud of it.
Some of them had never
heard of the school.
And they were like, they
knew that I worried,
that I worked hard in order
so that I could be able to help
my parents out financially.
And that meant a lot to them.
The gay stuff, I didn't volunteer it.
But I said, I talked about my partner.
It helps that pronouns don't
often come up in Spanish
but I would be like, "Oh yes,
I have to go to my partner"
and blah, blah, blah.
If someone I felt was extremely religious,
I would say partner and repeat
partner and avoid pronouns.
But most people, I was just open with
because I felt like if they
were uncomfortable with me
being queer and being this,
like, we wouldn't have the
level of intimacy required
to form the story that we
needed to form together.
And I could just find another subject.
- So last question, oldie
but goodie important
given the population, the
imagined population audience
for this conversation is,
what advice do you have for
aspiring Latinx writers?
And if you wanna just
wrap up into any of that
any closing thoughts
you wanna leave us with?
- I would say, read a lot.
I would say don't...
I would say don't listen to what
Hollywood representations of Latinx people
have to say about our own representation.
They're not leading the way here.
I think we're in a
really interesting moment
where immigrant artists and Latinx artists
are trying to do really cool
things with voice and genre.
Like, I don't know if y'all have read
Marcelo Hernandez Castillo's
"Children of the Land."
He's a undocumented author,
I think on his way to permanent
residency or something.
He's a poet and he wrote
a really cool book.
Jenny Zhang was never undocumented,
but she grew up in Queens,
grew up as an immigrant
and her book is vulgar and
filthy and wacky and crazy
and, you know, Salvador
Plascencia's "People of Paper,"
which I, you know, I
learned from Albert is,
you know, great book.
I would say kill your idols,
you know, commit matricide and patricide,
like stop looking at Julia
Alvarez and Sandra Cisneros
and, you know, all of those ladies.
And stop looking at Gloria
Anzaldúa and all of that,
like it's past that, it's 2020.
Like start looking
elsewhere for inspiration.
Like there are some books that I'm reading
that are coming out now that
are still describing our skin
as like (speaks in Spanish) skin
and are still saying that
our parents are strong
and can handle anything.
And that they just like pray
to the (speaks in Spanish)
and everything will be okay.
And that is tired.
And it's this like incestuous relationship
that the publishing
industry has with Hollywood.
And that is what has created the backdrop
for what we think we need to sound like.
And we don't, we don't.
And you will receive pushback
for not sounding like that,
but our canon is young.
Our Canon is young but
we need to push forward
because this is like
such an important time
to really experiment and to
really support each other
as we create some, you
know, really powerful art
because if we're creating
art where if you like,
take a person who's like
been in a bunker for 50 years
and is like, "Was this
produced in the '90s
"or was this produced in 2020?"
And if they can't tell the difference,
like, you writing it was a waste of time.
- Well said.
Well, that's the time we have today.
MJ, were you gonna jump on
for any closing thoughts?
I mean, I'm happy.
Thank you, Karla, obviously
for taking the time to chat.
Thanks to everyone for logging
on, follow the conversation.
MJ, you wanna take the mic here?
- Just wanna thank you both so so so much,
it was an amazing event.
For our audiences, thank
you for joining us.
I am linking our social media on the chat.
Please follow us.
There will be many more
events to come, keep in touch.
So thank you all.
- Thanks for coming.
- Take care, everyone.